if a girl has a hoe face why does the
women get to blame it on the men
pressuring her or get to blame it on her
being broken
and at 28 29 find God
and resave herself for marriage with a
husband
but but if a man sleeps around and has a
hoe face
nobody what I'm not having the whole
face well you know if I I mean they say
like go sew your Wild Oats in your 20s
right they'll say yeah they'll say you
know go around do your thing as a guy in
your 20s but he doesn't get to blame it
on his Brokenness he it's just just that
he was corny yeah a girl she could say I
was so broken I was so lost and at 28 29
right when I'm running out of time now
is my time to find God we're trying to
find myself who takes him seriously when
they say no but this is this is where
men have to take accountability and I
mean The simpy Men Who the reality is
they're allowed to do that because and
usually those kind of women who find God
end up with that guy that wasn't their
plan a it was probably their plan Zed
but bro that's not necessarily their
fault because if you're going to be real
yeah we already know the small
percentage of men that actually get play
anyway these men are just grateful for
an opportunity to be on the pitch you
know that monster is like yo the manager
called man up yeah everybody's one
minute left
at the time I just wanted
my legs under I might not touch them
sure I'll wait even though you got two
kids two different babies that's what
I'm saying I might not touch the boo
yeah but I can wait it's another cap you
know what I'm saying so they might
aren't here saying you know what I've
been waiting so I'm gonna get out here
and this is what it is when they're
younger they do all the madness and then
some soccer ends up picking them up yeah
but he's happy he's not a soccer he's
happy though no but he's happy until his
decision until until she gets the kids
and he has a sexless marriage because
she's not attracted to him that was his
decision that's it you should know about
that before he went into the a lot of
Sims don't know that though yeah that's
what I'm saying I think a lot of guys
don't know the games like how would they
know they haven't dealt with women but
again so when a girl when a girl comes
in at 28 29 and she says I was so broken
like this was like he believes her
because he doesn't he doesn't know these
girls are crazy that's because he wants
to believe her because he's desperate 20
years ago I'd agree with you but I think
the problem is the information is out
readily available now yeah if you don't
know that that's on you you know that's
on you not doing your research yeah but
when you're actually in it and you've
never had everyone knows that you know
when you when you're young if you used
to get in like you know when you're 15
you have that one girl that she violated
and you learn from that when you're like
15 and all the olders will tell you
she's doing amazing but you're waiting
like no I like this girl and you learn
but these men are learning in their 30s
but against once they're married someone
are told by the olders oh she's doing a
Madness and still won't listen they
choose not to listen bro that's because
their options do that man but this is
what I'm saying though you can't just
keep saying as a younger because you
know s on you what you decide I think
this just goes down to a lot of men
ain't disciplined that's plain and
simple yes a lot of us we think of our
Willies you go and say a lot a lot of us
have taken the time out again we've
meant to get to know ourselves so that
you don't remove yourself from certain
situations because cool like you said I
know my name on the Block when he was
young that when they took like their
wife not greases this girl step with the
whole block but because she slept with
me that means there must be something
there there must be something there yeah
bro it's easier it's easier to turn down
food here when you know when you where
your next meals come in you understand
what I'm saying bro like these men it
had nothing like their whole life they
got no play they probably spent their
20s watching and listening to their
virgins talk about the madness they were
doing and then they see a girl that they
know is out of their league now do you
know what I mean and all of a sudden
she's interested someone's like right
it's my time you know I'm saying so
man's gonna deal with all the nonsense
okay I think that goes to people don't
know value because so when does
accountability step in now because you
guys are using totally different terms
like you're leaving out all of the
accountability when on a woman I don't
think I am where's it you you absolutely
no we just said that simply men need to
be accountable though we literally said
it no you used a different term what you
said is that you said it was that
they're not disciplined
accountability so can we be like that
discipline the whole point is men deal
with the consequences because men get
the consequences
he's got a wife that's ran through and
there's consequences that come with a
wife that's random no but you're right
and I'm not but the point is that women
in society can do what they want and
there's no consequence
let me finish so I'm saying she gets to
do her thing in her whole face and she
still gets a ring and she still gets
kids with it with a husband the man he
when he marries a hoe she divorces him
the consequence of a woman being run
through and you know used up or whatever
and then getting married but to a guy
that she doesn't want isn't that a
consequence I think the kid's more
important than them is that a concert I
think it's a consequence no because
she'll just leave man yeah because she
just leaves him after the kids and then
goes back to the streets exactly exactly
what Kim done Kim literally got Kanye do
you know what I'm saying I got the full
use yeah I got a little mix of his
babies I'm cut are you mad and now she's
with peace
yeah I was literally like have you
forgotten the taking Hearts bro they're
not getting divorced bro I promise you
they're gonna stay married you are
alimonious a woman a woman gets money
just for being married to a guy for a
long time
you can get a job in some cases Dr Dre's
wife did you see how much he's paying
for her phone bill she'll ask you for
more and I don't understand because you
can get a job like why are you entitled
to his money because the laws are okay
that's why but they're married women we
weren't talking about married women
leaving we were talking about somebody
who had been run through on the streets
that had two kids and then now managed
to find a room yeah so that's married
yes yes now she's married to the dude
but he's not the father of her kids
right I mean she might give him more
kids I don't know yeah
look at Sierra look at Sierra she's not
gonna be cool with that what she's
probably gonna be cool okay let's take
with the next guy that she is with well
that's I mean look at Sierra what
happened with her so what did she do she
she got ran through by Future ran
throughout all the rappers finds God 28
29 settles down with Russell Wilson it
seems okay for a little bit now what's
she doing she's twerking on Instagram
the disrespect yeah
no she is an artist she used to twerk on
Instagram when you're married
so she's not able to twerk now
she was an artist well she said she said
she found God so she gave Russell Wilson
the impression she waited a year to
sleep with him and she gave him the
impression that she was a changed woman
now after she gets the kids and the
resources she's twerking on Instagram I
think that's disrespectful as a wife
there are things you can do when you are
single that I don't think you should do
if you are married preach no so I think
it's between her and her man and he
doesn't seem to care that she's twerking
and whoever that goes against me and
that's why okay guys what do you what
would you call him how do you know
how do you know that he doesn't mind I
feel like he just he don't have a say
like it's not that he doesn't mind like
my man's doing the office I'm telling
you wait can I just say something he
doesn't have a say because there was a
video where she was literally getting
ready and I think I saw it yesterday
also and like she was getting ready and
he was like Sierra we gotta go and she
was ignoring him like
you take your time and they are going to
be like let's leave now and you are
going to be like there's a certain level
of disrespect that happened there yeah
that only a man that is aware can see
that one's happening
do you like masculine or feminine
masculine men are you sure so so I'm
confused so like with what we're
describing you seem to be quite okay
with a lot of the way a lot of these
women behave could you feel like you
could behave that with a masculine man
it's the Dynamics of being in a
relationship like literally you are
going to be running late as a woman it's
gonna happen and the guy is gonna be
like let's leave now and you're still
going to be getting ready
wait sorry so this is what we mean about
accountability all you're doing right
now is giving excuse after excuse
afterwards I'm giving you enough excuse
for the woman to get away of watching
the bad behavior that's clearly
portrayed and then it's funny because
whenever
whenever something for the man comes up
you always try to put accountability on
him and then take it off
because there's yeah there's too much
one-sidedness on the women being all
accountable and it's like but what about
the matter well I think it evens that
because Society always takes
accountability off of women but it
doesn't oh my goodness
name one double standard outside of body
count that does not benefit women
you give me one and I'll be able to
disprove it because one that does
benefit women we get drinks for free we
get free on the first dates we get into
clubs for free